post-credit scenes are all the rage
these days but before those became
popular some movies included jokes or
hidden references within the actual
credits themselves here are some of our
favorites from new and old movies alike
frozen boogers being a Disney hero is
hungry work
luckily Kristoff and frozen found the
perfect snack to fortify him his own
boogers what have you hate the way he
picks his nose his nose and eats it
excuse me sir he's a prince all men do
it you even Disney thought that was a
bit gross though
adding this disclaimer to the credits
the views and opinions expressed by
Kristoff in this film that all men eat
their own boogers are solely his and do
not necessarily reflect the views or
opinions of the Walt Disney Company or
the filmmakers do no harm when a movie
involves any kinds of animals or
creatures it's always important for the
filmmakers to ensure the critters is
safety even if those animals are CGI pay
close attention to the credits and
guardians of the galaxy and you'll see
confirmation that no raccoons or tree
creatures were in any way harmed during
the production of the film in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire we learned
that no dragons were harmed in the
making of this movie and mr. Popper's
Penguins assures us that no Penguins
were harmed but Jim Carrey on the other
hand was bitten mercilessly but he had
it coming no argument here
meanwhile The Naked Gun Flex apparently
reveled in animal cruelty claiming in
the credits that some entire species
went extinct during principal
photography nice Bieber thank you I just
had it stuffed let me help you with that
coffee shop when the Supreme Court ruled
that corporations are people they base
their decision on pulp fiction okay
that's not true but it could have been
why during the robbery scene the
restaurant managers dialogue was so
obscured by screaming and swearing that
all he could get out was this I am NOT a
hero and just coffee so in the credits
Quentin Tarantino decides to simply name
him coffee shop cozy in the closet the
end credits of Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban gives viewers a long
look at the infamous Marauders map which
shows the layout of Hogwarts and all the
folks sneaking around its hallways and
rooms for a moment during the credits
however we see two pairs of feet in the
corner of the screen that don't really
sneak so much as they seem like they
might be knocking boots who do you think
it might be our money is on Professor
McGonagall and Professor Flitwick Yanks
hello Hans Oh director JJ Abrams doesn't
shy away from throwing fun Easter eggs
into his projects usually it's just Greg
Grunberg but during the credits of 2006
is mission impossible 3 the film makers
give a special thanks to the honza
Foundation of course true fans will
recognize the honza Foundation as the
mysterious group that had a hand in all
the crazy Island shenanigans on Abrams
television projects lost maybe jack and
the rest of the gang got stranded all
because of that damn rabbit's foot
you have 15 seconds to comply most
movies contain a warning that the film
is protected under copyright laws in the
United States followed by some legal
mumbo-jumbo it's the same disclaimer
every time except in the case of Robocop
I'd buy that for a dollar at the end of
the Paul Verhoeven film the disclaimer
reads unauthorized duplication
distribution or exhibition may results
in civil liability and criminal
prosecution by enforcement droids
in other words pirate Robocop and you
may get a visit from Edie 209 thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which movies you think
should have made the list